so hold on japanese machinery made in
america and we're saying that they're
chinese
yes
i know some facts about fortune cookies
and i know how to make them so let's
teach each other perfect cool
[Music]
wait wait can i tell you a story real
quick sure
it's 2005 the powerball is at 25 million
dollars and you're eating take out for
the third night in a row you break open
a fortune cookie and it reads all the
preparation you've done will finally be
paying off the lucky numbers are 22 28
32 33 39 40. you play them because why
not and you win second place along with
109 other people
the lottery investigates and learns that
everyone played the lucky numbers from
the same fortune if only you'd played 42
instead of 40 you'd have hit the jackpot
that's crazy how did fortune cookies
come to the u.s well let's go back to
1983.
[Music]
san francisco and los angeles are facing
off in court sort of it's just a mock
trial to determine who invented the
fortune cookie you see san francisco
claims that prior to world war one
makoto hagawara a japanese immigrant and
the landscape designer of the japanese
tea garden in golden gate park would
serve the cookies to visitors los
angeles argues that david jung a chinese
immigrant and founder of the hong kong
noodle company invented the cookies
which it's been said were called fortune
tea cakes the judge chooses san
francisco but doesn't weigh in on
whether they're japanese or chinese
1981
young lee a korean immigrant patents the
fortune 3 the world's first fully
automated fortune cookie machine this is
a huge step forward for fortune cookie
production but it's not the first
machine
seven years earlier edward louis owner
of the lotus fortune cookie company
invents the first machine that can place
a fortune in the cookie and fold it up
that's amazing
[Music]
so making fortune cookies is actually
fairly easy the first thing we're gonna
do is add egg whites and then vanilla so
you're just gonna whisk it until frothy
so next add the flour and we're gonna
sift that into the bowl
sugar
pinch of salt and next we're going to
combine it all with a spatula and this
is
kind of similar to making macarons like
that's about the texture we're gonna get
once it's paste like um we're gonna add
a little water and i found that it takes
about three tablespoons but you should
add it gradually
the batter should loosen up a bit and
fall with ribbons like that look how
beautiful nice so then you have two
options you can do this with a
rimmed cookie cutter to give you some
guidelines or just take a tablespoon and
eyeball it the other important thing to
note is that you can only make two at a
time basically that's just because if
you make more they'll just firm up into
cookies rather than being able to be
folded into fortunes
it's the 1950s babies are booming elvis
is singing and by the end of the decade
americans are cracking over 250 million
cookies a year chinese restaurants are
handing out fortune cookies all across
the country
[Music]
world war ii is over and fortune cookies
are going national as soldiers return
from the pacific they pass through west
coast chinese restaurants before heading
home where they request the relatively
unheard of cookies from very confused
restaurant owners they oblige place
orders and the cookies spread all over
the country now around the same time the
office of price administration removes
chinese fortune tea cakes from its
control list which means fortune cookies
are chinese right
[Music]
to make a fortune cookie you've gotta
work pretty quickly
take a fortune
fold it over and then fold it in half
voila pop in the little muffin tin all
right let me try i believe in me i
believe in you no i don't i don't yes
you can okay
oh that's hot
okay quickly quickly quickly quickly yes
yes yes look at it i can live with that
we've got so many more to go
let's do this
on february 19 1942 franklin delano
roosevelt authorizes executive order
9066 which allows for the forcible
relocation of japanese americans to
internment camps this order would not be
lifted for three years causing many
japanese businesses to close chinese
business owners step in to satisfy the
increased demand for chinese food
prior to the war some chinese
restaurants are owned by japanese
families there's very little demand for
traditional japanese cuisine at the time
so to make a living some people open
chinese restaurants some small japanese
influences are able to work their way in
[Music]
1914 makoto hagawara reportedly
introduces the fortune cookie to the u.s
though it is called senbei which can be
translated from japanese to cracker he
presents them to the guests at golden
gate park with the help of a local sweet
shop but the fortune cookie didn't just
come from nowhere
[Music]
kyoto home of tsujiura senbei the
possible precursor to the fortune cookie
it's darker larger and the fortune is
tucked into the knuckle but the shape is
the exact same researchers have found
documentation of the cracker as far back
as the early 1800s and that's it that's
where some people think the fortune
cookie comes from all right so we've
tried to recreate sujira senbei and we
couldn't because it was impossible to
find a recipe we searched all over the
internet we got tasty japan involved and
we just couldn't find a recipe but we do
know a few things about them we know
that they have miso and they have sesame
they're less sweet they're more on the
savory side but we really couldn't track
down a recipe so this is you know our
interpretation darn i know next time
next time next time we'll take a trip
three two one
oh god
you're a queen everyone is fighting
their own battles oh
i like mine better that yours is better
[Music]
you